[Music]
jurassic world's much anticipated third
part will finally hit theaters in less
than a year from now there has been a
lot going on around the franchise in
recent months observant fans have thus
been able to find an increasing number
of set pictures and other facts about
jurassic world dominion on the internet
in order to save you the trouble of
searching for them yourself we have
summarized everything you need to know
about the cast the plot and the new
dinosaurs in this video as always we
start off with a little recap of the
second part of jurassic world therefore
if you haven't seen it you should skip
forward now
ilan nubla's volcano is about to erupt
causing mankind to deal with the
question of whether they bear any
responsibility to help out the dinos
owen grady clear deering and the rest
come to a decision and set out on a
journey to save the creatures first they
track down the female velociraptor blue
who still shares a bond with own rescue
operation is financially supported by
the lockwood family which has been
involved in the project since a park was
founded it soon turns out that they
don't really want to save the dinos they
merely want to capture them and sell
them to the highest bidder also involved
is the indoraptor a new crossbreed
species whose attacks can be controlled
with laser targeting the dinosaurs are
taken to the lockwood is a state where
owen and claire attempt to set them free
among the confusion the indirector also
escapes and now preys on the buyers and
the others present while fleeing from
the hunter they meet lockwood's
granddaughter macy who's actually clone
of his young disease daughter blue
manages to break free as well and
together with grady she takes up the
fight against the interrupter in the
final battle the two raptors fall
through the roof of the building and the
super dinosaur is impaled on the fossil
skull of the triceratops but through a
hole in a hydrogen sinai tank toxic gas
is leaking out which is about to kill
all the trapped dinosaurs as a result
the heroes decide to release them into
the wild in the final scene we get to
see t-rex and a lion yelling at each
other in the zoo and so ends part two
but what awaits us in part
three aside from raptor trainer old
grady the top clear gearing will of
course also take on a leading role again
both will be played as expected by
marvel star chris pratt and bryce dallas
howard another five other familiar faces
from the jurassic world series will also
be back the nervous system analyst
franklin webb will support the heroes
and the new adventure as previously also
joining them as his intelligent
colleague dr zia rodriguez both had
already played a significant role in the
second part to save the dinosaurs from
their demise just like before they are
embodied by justice smith and daniela
pineda for both of them jurassic world
the fallen kingdom was their first major
role in hollywood isabella sermon as
macy lockwood will also be making
another appearance exactly what kind of
role the clone of the late billionaire's
daughter will play is sure to be
interesting above all it was her beliefs
that ultimately were the deciding factor
in releasing the dinos into the wild yet
it is not only from the second part that
the dinosaur friends will get support
characters from the first movie released
in 2014 are also joining in with barry
simban the second raptor trainer from
jurassic world returns to the series he
is played by omar sai he is a good
friend of own and will presumably join
him on the search for the escaped raptor
blue
actually already announced but now
unfortunately cancelled is laura
cruthers the security technician from
part one who is played by new girl star
jake johnson unfortunately had to be cut
from the script afterwards this is
explained by the fact that johnson was
unable to make it to the shoot on time
due to unfavorable circumstances over
the past two years opting instead to
stay with his family however he
emphasized in the interview that he
still has hopes of perhaps making it
into the film through post-production so
far unfortunately it doesn't look like
he will
fans of the 90 series can rejoice not
only will chaos theorist dr ian malcolm
who already had a small role in the
fallen kingdom be featured again also
starring this time our former
protagonist dr alan grant and dr ali
sadler for both it's the first
appearance since jurassic park 3 from
2001. the recognized paleontologist and
the paleobotanist will surely be in
great demand now that the dinos are
expanding across the united states in an
interview director colin trevorrow also
expressed that the roles of the three
veteran stars should not be
underestimated especially when it comes
to creating a connection between the
parts thus fans can look forward to the
trio being given quite a bit of screen
time ian malcolm will of course be
played by jeff goldblum again just as
emil and laura dern will be cast as the
two natural scientists in addition to
the three main actors from the first
trilogy bd wong is also part of the cast
as the genetic engineer dr henry wu just
like goldblum he could already be seen
on the big screen in other parts of
jurassic world also for the first time
since their first part lewis dodgson
will be playing a role in the movie but
wait a minute who's this supposed to be
you ask well rightly so as he will
probably be remembered by very few
people it was him who handed dennis
naderi the shaving cream can with which
he was supposed to steal the dinosaur
embryos from illinois in the first
minutes of jurassic park we can only
speculate how the character will
translate into the new movie even that
he didn't make any further appearances
apart from this scene he is the only one
who was recast as well this time dodgson
gets played by campbell scott instead of
cameron thores in 1993. indeed in 2016
the latter was sentenced to six years in
prison for sexually molesting minors
the star ensemble will be expanded
further with the addition of the
wonderwise and mama do a fee so far
nothing is known about their road sadly
and the revival of the all-stars also
leaves the question unanswered as to how
big the roads are going to be beforehand
however they always talk of a leading
role whether they're dinosaur friends or
post remains to be seen in any case
we're intriguing to look forward to the
two newcomers the cast also includes
dejan luckman and scott hayes but they
will likely be given smaller roles haze
has starred in vanaman zeroville in
recent years where zlackman is mostly
known from her acting in series
probably the biggest change in the team
is the director's choice with colin
trevorrow returning to the set he
directed the first part but gave up his
position for the benefit of the spaniard
j.a biona for the fallen kingdom
nevertheless he was never entirely gone
from the franchise as he contributed
further as a producer and screenwriter
responsible for the screenplay this time
are emily carmichael and derek connelly
carmichael's work is well known from
pacific rim uprising while derek
connolly has already worked on the first
two scripts the movie has a budget of
165 million us dollars that's 5 million
less than part 2. shooting began in
february 2020 and had to be discontinued
after not even a month due to the
ongoing pandemic luckily they were able
to finish at the end of november though
this was only accomplished under the
strictest conditions with around 40 000
rapid tests and additional costs of 9
million us dollars as a result of the
longer shooting period the film's
release has been postponed is now
scheduled for release on june 10th 2022
almost four years after the second part
there are several images from the set
and also a five minute preview which was
shown exclusively before fast and
furious 9 in imax theaters this allowed
us to see a list of the dinos which are
new or to be seen again it was clear
from the very first five minutes that
the creators will refrain from using new
genetically modified dinos in the third
part in favor of going back to the
paleontological approach well we don't
have to go into detail regarding old
favorites like the t-rex and the
velociraptors rather let's talk about
the dreadnoughtus which is very similar
to the brachiosaurus fossils of the
herbivore were actually discovered in
2005. other herbivores are the
nasutoceratops and the ruanodon
keslakotlus will also be featured as a
new race as pterosaurus whereas the
previously seen winged reptiles were
only seen slightly larger than humans
the castle cordless reaches the size of
a giraffe as the latest discovered
dinosaur we will have to deal with
moro's intrepidus this one could already
be marveled ahead in the 5 minute
preview in the imax theaters even the
small detail with the feathers is
intentionally presented after all some
scientific studies showed that dinosaurs
had at least imparts feathers the
leading paleontologists are not yet in
complete agreement about the feathering
nevertheless it's still great to see
that scientific findings are dealt with
in the film needless to say this time
the movie must also feature dinosaur
which is of particular worry to the
heroes and now the whole of humanity
this time around it will most likely be
the giganotosaurus
this is considered to be the largest
known carnivore that has ever existed on
land and was native to argentina
moreover some pictures surfaced on
twitter which showed another carnivore
namely the pyro raptor historically the
lizard hit dinosaur lived in what is now
provence france
what is clear is that the action will
take place around four years after the
dinosaurs broke out into the wild and
the images also reveal that the dinos
have reclaimed many parts of nature
however it is not supposed to be a mere
fighting spectacle between humans and
dinosaurs as fans can expect more of a
science thriller instead this is
certainly one reason why the stars of
the 90s have been brought back and will
play a bigger role according to the
director the main focus will be on
ethical and scientific matters and to
what extent they're compatible with one
another jeff goldblum recently even
hinted that the impact of the ongoing
pandemic is going to play part in the
film as well we are looking forward to
the last installment of the series as we
are sure that it will perfectly balance
the scientific aspect of the 90s with
the action of the new movies we cannot
predict when the first trailer will be
available but we are sure it will not
take much longer as usual you'll be able
to watch it on our channel as soon as it
is out
now you should be well prepared for the
new movie which dinosaur are you looking
forward to the most let us know in the
comments below we are eagerly awaiting
the first trailer in case there any
further news about the film you will of
course find them here in our weekly news
see you next time
you